so that's good i'm going to store that
away in the back of my mind in order to
use that i need a kind of equivalent
thing for particle b right so i'm going
to go all the way back to the beginning
i'm going to consider particle b now
and in some ways this part is a little
bit repetitive because i have to repeat
this process okay i'm going to say that
velocity is the change in displacement
over time so i've got this statement
here for a different particle now right
so this is what i got negative 4
16
take away just like before i'll take
reciprocals
and then of course i need to integrate
in order to get to a displacement
occasion that i can pop a time into okay
so having written this integral i'll
chuck that um constant at the front
morning
i've got this as my integrand which we
ought to oh that should be a b sorry
keep missing that
uh which we want to recognize as which
standard form what are we looking at
here this is sign inverse or
alternatively cos inverse but as you
guys know doesn't matter so i'm going to
use sine inverse here and i think that's
fine i've got the negative a quarter as
a constant hanging out the front what's
this going to become
x d on 4. right there's a squared minus
x squared in there that we saw before
okay
um and i've got another constant because
it's still in a definite integral okay
so
let's just say that's the sum whatever
okay lovely
now have a look at this pause for a
moment
what can i do with this you've
integrated successfully last time you
used this initial condition in order to
work out what the constant was what are
you going to do now
what are you going to do now because i
don't actually have an initial condition
for example
okay so so last time right i knew of
initially where i where i was starting
from but where this guy initially that's
the questions of course i don't know
that right i don't know where i start
but i do know where i'm supposed to end
and how long it's going to take me to
get there okay so i guess it's an
initial condition versus our final
condition okay so instead of using t
equals zero to evaluate this constant
i'm going to say
for particle b
to do the same thing here to reach the
origin
simultaneously with a that's what i'm
after
that word simultaneously it allows me to
use these two facts together a
displacement and a particular tone okay
so that's what that word means to me and
that's what i'm going to put in here
okay i think i'm going to slightly run
this space so i'll do it for you
i'm subbing in time equals power and 16.
i'm cybering in x b equals zero and that
should allow me to find the constant
okay so in other words what i'm gonna
get is negative one on four
sine inverse of uh this is zero right
this is zero
there's the constant that i'm trying to
evaluate
and this is how long it takes me to get
there yeah uh sinu message zero of
course is
zero so i just get the same concept that
i got before that's kind of nice so
for the second particle for particle b i
now have a complete displacement time
equation right so this is going to be i
need 1 over 4 sine inverse of that
plus closer
okay i'm almost there i'm on the final
leg
what do i do with this thing what am i
trying to solve
yeah initial condition like where am i
supposed to release this thing from so
at time zero what is excuse me what's
going on okay so therefore initially
initially when i put time
0 into here i'm going to say negative a
quarter sine inverse of
that thing which i'm trying to find out
that's where am i going to release from
plus pi over 16.
that's time zero right that makes sense
so i just need to tidy this up a tiny
little bit
it looks to me if i put this guy in the
other side but then write him on the
left because
the thing i'm trying to find is
necessary within that sine inverse i've
got this i can multiply through
laxo
now
don't just jump to the next line don't
just jump to the next line think about
what i'm going to have to do and i want
you to notice that you can't always just
do that operation that you're thinking
of that's in your mind what do i have to
do to both sides
i have to take sine of both sides okay
now you're probably thinking oh well
sinus so i can just write down x b on 4
equals sine pi over 4 which is 1 root
i would think oh that's what i'm going
to get it is what you're going to get
but you can't just do that right we
looked at what happens when you put
together trig functions with their
inverse trig you know reverses okay sine
of sine inverse of something
is not always just that thing okay sine
of i'm actually have another space
i'll write it here
so just
view this as a separate thing
sine of sine inverse of
whatever you like let's just say some
number okay okay it is equal to k
but only sometimes think back to your
inverse tree there's a restriction on
this what is it
okay so it's the restriction that exists
on this guy right like this guy doesn't
exist everywhere he only exists in a
certain few places for example if i said
to you hey sine inverse of like 5
that doesn't work because there's no
value there's no angle you can give me
that sine of that will give you 5
because of course the restriction on
sine inverse and cos inverse is going to
be from where to where
negative one to one okay negative one
one blessings okay
now hold on a second
is that is that okay
this seems to me like it's a bit of
initially when i look at this seems to
be a bit of a problem right because in
fact i'm not between negative one and
one am i
isn't that a problem
so
luckily for me and this is why all these
numbers are the way they are right i'm
not actually having sine of sine inverse
of some arbitrary number i have sine of
sine inverse of this divided by four so
actually you can write this line which
is absolutely true and from that you can
conclude well sine of sine inverse of
what i'm actually interested in
is x sub v on four now when is that x of
b on four and the answer is it's when x
of b on four is between negative one and
one
but but that's okay right because look
negative four
so four the first thing i want to point
out is that's okay with this but the
second thing i want to point out is i
actually should have written down that
lines and lines and lines ago where
where should you have already known that
was the case look carefully
the first time we talked about particle
b the first time we talked about
particle b
the second we wrote that we should have
noted there was a restriction right
because look you've got a square root
under here you've got take away x
squared so x can't just be anything you
like if x is too big it's absolute value
then you're going to get a negative
under the square root we're in real land
right so the second i wrote this i
really should have said right have a
look that thing under the square root
the smallest it can be a zero after that
i'm in trouble so therefore
i could have noted this at the beginning
okay and this is what rescues us over
here let's come back to our final
working
over here i can say this
because
i have a restriction on x b so i
actually can this is a legitimate line
of working just like we've been looking
at in inequalities you can't just
multiply and divide by or apply
functions just because you want to you
have to know oh all my numbers are real
or i have some kind of restriction on an
x which lets me do this okay so i'm
going to invoke that negative four
to four okay
and then finally that lets me get to
finish off
and you can tidy that up if you want by
saying therefore we need to release
particle b two root two units on the
positive side of the origin and um
that's it okay